had high hopes for political change
after the move forward party emerged as
the biggest winner in the general
election in me
he voted for the party because it
promised economic and political reforms
including a move to amend laws that
severely punish anyone who insults the
monarchy
two months later with no government in
place tachapong's hopes are turning to
disappointment
we have done what we can we tried to use
the tool of democracy we showed our
voice in the election it was the best
and most peaceful way for the people to
show their power but the Senators
crushed our voices
leader of move forward and his allies
have a majority in the lower house but
needed votes from the mostly
military-appointed Senate to be elected
prime minister Peter received 13 votes
from Senators the rest either abstained
or voted against him move forward and
its Alliance Partners must now decide
whether to resubmit his name in another
vote next week or put forward a new
candidate economists say political
uncertainty will damage investor
confidence many ties are already
struggling with the cost of living and
inflation which saw it to a 24-year high
last year
who owns a small food store is finding
it harder to make even a small profit
I want things to change I want democracy
I don't think I can take this anymore
the people are suffering and the
government doesn't do much for the
people
move forward's planned economic reforms
could be canceled they would include
dismantling business monopolies which
control a range of industries from
popular beer companies to
Telecommunications
I think it's a lost opportunity for the
country laws that prevent small
businesses from competing against giant
companies have existed for a long time
without help for the government it will
be very difficult for the little guys to
compete
but mostly he's Furious that the outcome
of the general election is not being
reflected in government and says there's
a chance that people will take to the
streets
it's not right it's going to be ugly but
someone has to do it
the mood among those who voted for
change could slowly turn from Hopeful to
angry Florence Louis Al Jazeera Bangkok